he's known literally throughout the
Universe for his groundbreaking
discoveries in the field of string
theory he co-invented mirror symmetry
and he brought the notion of calabi Yao
manifolds to the mainstream meet the one
and only Brian Green Brian's a professor
of physics and math at Columbia
University and the author of numerous
best-selling books join us on this
in-person
conversation held late at night at
Columbia University as we uncover the h
reality of our universe and delve into
parallel universes and the Deep
Mysteries of the fabric of reality let's
go so welcome back everybody you're here
with the extended overtime with a
brilliant inspiring mentor to Millions
around the world Brian Green and yours
truly Brian keing and I love to ask
these questions that humanized
scientists and I think you do a
wonderful job you and Tracy and your
whole team at the world Science Festival
of showing scientists as human beings
and there's this you know kind of that
were just these monotonous robots who
you know can only tell a scientist is
outgo do you know how to tell if a
scientist is outgoing or not how when he
looks at your shoes when he talks uh so
that's that's an old but um but I like
to humanize you've been you've done so
much stuff there's no shortage of
humanization for a wonderful person such
as yourself but I love to ask these
questions to get to kind of the the soul
of hidden reality to to use a phrase
that you uh that you coined or Twisted
they're all related in some way to
Arthur C Clark because the name of this
podcast the into the impossible podcast
as you'll find out if you don't know
came from Sir Arthur C Clark's sentiment
he was very quip worthy and one of his
quips was the only way of determining
the limits of the possible is to go
beyond them into the impossible and so
at UC San Diego I'm the associate
director of the Arthur C Clark Center
for human imagination long-winded way to
say that we're going to talk about all
these different things related to Arthur
C Clark I assume you've seen 2001 A
Space Odyssey not in a long time I
didn't mean either but I saw it in 2001
but in that movie there are these
strange things these monoliths that open
in the beginning of the movie there are
these baboon type things hominids in the
savannah of Africa hitting it with a
bone trying to crack it open and then
later on they appear on the moon and
they're floating around in Spain we're
not really sure what they are these
Sentinels as they're described in the
book and the question I kind of want to
ask you about is if you had uh if these
things were time capsules and you could
put anything from the human you know
collection of of wisdom knowledge
acquisition and you could describe it or
put it in there put it on there for an
alien civilization to find a billion
years hence what would it be what would
be sort of the crown jewel of humankind
maybe maybe your work or or you know
what have you but but it could be I'm
I'm not saying that you would say that
but but people have said that I mean cun
said String Theory uh but I want ask
what would you put on it Fineman said
the atomic hypothesis something that
would be be you know betray or be speak
of this Swagger that human beings should
have the confidence that we should have
in our past accomplishments what would
it be yeah I mean from the from the
science point of view a competitor to
Fan's statement that the atomic
hypothesis is the most fundamental thing
that that we have discovered the
competitor I would say is that symmetry
is the key to understanding the cosmos
and so I would be happy to have the
gauge group of the standard model
inscribed I'd be happy to have the
unifying groups that we discussed
earlier su5 su1
E6 I I I would want to have the lorence
group included you know su3 one so to me
symmetry is really the the Deep lesson
that emerges over the last few hundred
years now having said that that's just
sort of on the science side of things if
you ask me what I would really want to
put in there to capture
the human spirit I go in a direction
that some of your
listeners might be less pleased to hear
me say I think the most vital thing that
we humans do is try to understand our
place in a greater Cosmic order and
there are many ways that we've tried to
do that religion is one of those ways
religion is not the answer to Scientific
questions but does it
wonderfully illustrate the Deep urge
that we have to feel part of something
grander I think that really does say
something about us so I'd want to
include that I want to include the great
musical compositions that have that
longing and that urgent sense of trying
to understand the world from brahs and
Beethoven to Bach I mean there are so
many deeply moving and poetic ways that
again we've tried to understand how we
fit in so yes science is part of it but
the great movements be it in music be it
in philosophy be in religion I all feel
that they're part of a human narrative
that tries to say here we are these
little beings crawling around the
surface of this nondescript planet in
the outskirts of this absolutely
ordinary Galaxy and how do we make sense
of that and here are the various ways
that we've gone about it well it's very
uh it's very s serendipitous that you
say that I asked that of anurian as I
asked all my uh guests that honor me by
coming on and I said what would you put
on a time capsule that last billion
years oh I did that yeah that's true she
did Voyager golden record actually what
she put on it is hearkens back to it was
the first example of ethno music you
know World music put on samples from all
these and and she also they had her uh
EK uh EKG no ECG they scanned her brain
EEG where they scanned her brain and she
was just had fallen in love with Carl
and so that's on a record flying you
know on its way to proximate centu the
next kind of uh call out shout out to
Sir Arthur C Clark is his famous phrase
that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic so tell me what technology you're
a theorist but but what technology is
most exciting to you that either in
physics and science or could be in in
you know in the commercial sphere AI it
could be I mean it's not particularly
original you just mentioned I would say
that AI at the you play around I I've
played around with it we did actually a
program at the world Science Festival in
September on it which will be coming out
at some point and in order to
familiarize myself more fully I actually
went back to some of the original papers
learned about neural Nets learned about
Transformer architectures kind of wanted
to understand that the basis of it all
number one what I found is
mathematically it is really
straightforward yeah incredibly St
and number two number two what it really
does highlight is when you have
sufficiently large data sets that of
course you have to analyze in the right
way when you have patterns of patterns
of patterns of patterns of patterns of
patterns of words that hierarchy of
patterns yields behaviors and insights
that feel very human they're not human
but they feel really human and there's
something deeply compelling and also to
some deeply frightening I just give you
one little example that really kind of
caught my attention we discussed it a
bit in this program I I wanted to see
how one of these large language models
deals with information that's false
because that's obviously something that
we're all worried about you know
misinformation deep fakes and so forth
and I said to the system if I told you
that seven time 8 is 62 not 56 how would
you make sense of it and the assistant
came back with five explanations but two
of them were particularly interesting
the first one was maybe you're working
in a different base not base 10 and
indeed I was I was working in base nine
and it worked it out that I thought was
like pretty creative okay number two it
said maybe it's metaphorical I was like
that's interesting can you expand on
that and the system said yes imagine
there's a land called
numeria in which seven represents truth
and eight represents friendship and 62
represents the deep bond between people
that share truth and friendship so when
people get together they exchange tokens
it said a seven and an eight and that
puts them together in this Union called
62 and I looked at this thing I'm I I
know it's not a human I know it's not
intelligent in the way that we normally
think about intelligence as human being
but it was really kind of an amazing
moment so it feels to me that we may be
at one of those rare inflection points
where things really change I I love AI
especially when it hallucinates because
I'll ask it who is Brian keing you say
Brian keing is a cosmologist check uh
University of California San Diego check
he's the author of losing the Nobel
Prize check into the impossible check
the elegant Universe yeah so my book
sales go up and my Amazon ranking seems
High um but actually I think about and
maybe just a quick diversion you know
when you think about um what Einstein
called his happiest thought the thought
that gave heart palpitation yeah it was
the Einstein equivalence principle that
an observer in freef Fall Would
experience no gravitational F like I'm
the the tail wagging the dog you don't
even me to teach it but but that was
what he said now I ask you Brian to what
extent could a computer have a happy
thought could it View and and value
embodiment and visceral sensation I've
had n chsky on he believes it's not
possible there's something about the
visceral nature of the human body that
leads to generative intelligence of a
true nature like creating the Einstein
equivalence principle do you think we'll
have you know AI AE artificial
intelligent Albert Einsteins or do you
think they'll just kind of supplement
maybe they can retrodict but they won't
be able to predict new laws of physes no
I I unlike N chsky I really don't think
there's any special about the substrate
called the human body or even the human
brain I again don't know but my
suspicion is that if you have a
sufficiently powerful computational
system along with that computational
power comes a certain kind of conscious
sensation so I really don't see
Consciousness as something special
that's added on top or needs a body or
needs Flesh and Blood I see it as
something that goes hand inand with a
certain depth of computational capacity
so I really do think we'll have
artificial systems that have
Sensations and that truly are feeling
them and look it's very difficult to
check that I don't even know if you're
having real Sensations I think you are
based upon my understanding and my
theory of mind and every piece of data
suggests that we're very similar in
terms of roughly speaking the kind of
experiences right but but you know when
it comes to a a system artificial system
it'll be very hard to check it just like
it's hard to check for you but if that
system is crying and really tells me
it's depressed and explains me why it's
depressed circuit for it I blew a
capacitor I think it'll be pretty
convincing you know I used to drop um my
former department chair Dimitri basov I
used to drop on him the following quip
from Sir Arthur uh he used to say for
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert um so whenever Demitri
would give me too many Community
assignments and I hope you'll give him
my best when you see him my chair too by
the way just everybody now you stole
them away this's a guy who told me that
we hired you Brian because we think you
win a Nobel Prize someday and I and I
didn't know who he was at the time but
you know was early on in my career and I
looked up who's Nikolai bass off you
know look up who that is uh that was his
dad coinventor of the laser didn't along
with a former Dennis in this building
Charlie towns oh yeah a deep connection
between Columbia Ander any Lear amazing
the quote that I want to turn to now is
the following Sir Arthur said when an
elder God forbid hasta shalam I'm
calling you elderly but when an elderly
but distinguished scientist says
something is possible he is very likely
to be right but when he says something
is impossible he's very likely wrong I
ask you Brian what have you been wrong
about if anything what have you changed
your mind about what would you like a
mulligan over I for instance never
thought that we would have a real
proposal for the foundational equations
of strength Theory by today and because
of this work that goes by the name of
duality in ADF CFT correspondence we
really close to that at least in certain
circumstances and so that to me was
something that was like a hundred or 200
years off back say in the 80s and early
90s and was completely wrong on that
front gravitational waves when I'd hear
people talk about gravitational wave
detectors I couldn't help but laugh it's
impossible you know back in the 80s and
90s it was just impossible you will
never be able to do this thing you know
and and yet you know we now have
directed 2015 so it didn't even take a
hundred years right it just took you
know 20 years from the time that I
thought it would be impossible so yes
I'm continually Amazed by what my
colleagues are able to do do and you're
right I mean you basically need to tell
the right experimentor that something's
impossible and then 20 years later do it
and do it yeah all right Brian the last
question hearkens back to the name of
this podcast the into the impossible
podcast and as I said before the
statement by Sir Arthur is kind of
evocative to me of sort of advice to
your former self and the statement goes
like this said the only way of
determining the limits of what's
possible is to go beyond those limits
into the impossible that's the name of
my podcast I want to ask you in the form
of advice to 20-year-old Brian now we're
going back in time instead of forward in
time billions of years now we're going
back 20 30 40 years and that is the
following what would you say to a
20-year-old Brian you have 30 seconds
with him to give him the courage to do
as you've done to go into the impossible
to remove the unknown and take away that
anxiety about the future perhaps what
and this could be not in physics yeah
this could be in life it could be you
know buy Bitcoin whatever you want what
advice would you give to this young
Brian to give him the courage to do as
you've done to go into the impost yeah I
guess I would say be willing to take
deep
chances I think in my career I've
definitely taken chances I've worked on
things that were highly speculative that
perhaps wouldn't work out and some of
them did some of them didn't but if I
was to go back the thing that I'd want
to change is to be even more bold and be
willing to be that much more wrong and
be willing to have complete
failure and I don't think there many
times when I wasn't willing to have
complete failure I'd be working on
things that were difficult and hard but
I could sort of see a trajectory toward
the finish line and when you look at
some of the scientists who have really
changed everything many of them were
working on something that nobody would
go near because it just seemed beyond
the reach of a human being at least at
this particular point in our
understanding and you know the problem
with that of course is most of the time
people who take that advice will fail
rarely however they will succeed and it
feels to me that it's worth that chance
and I think I'm gonna encourage at least
a younger version of myself to go for it
even more than perhaps I actually did
well Brian Green uh renowned just mentor
to Millions literally you've been
mentoring two of my friends who are no
longer in physics were inspired mentored
by you remotely through your uh
phenomenal writing and they asked me to
send you uh their gratitude as as I have
benefited and so many around the world
and I don't want toh keep you up any
longer with your list of accomplishments
with Ryan green thank you so much for
spending a late night on a Monday night
coming back from wherever you had to
come back from uh to spend a little bit
of time with my audience is thirsty for
your wisdom thank you sir well thank you
very enjoyable thank you it's great